hola profesores de méxico los invito al
campeonato de carga de amstel container
de la progresión para carmen bernal es
horrible existen tales productos google
el campeonato cargarme
[Música]
en escuelas
en su dni
ex side
[Aplausos]
[Música]
hola soy leonor de canadevi mexico para
este regreso a clases
khan academy lanzará un reto a nivel
nacional para impulsar el aprendizaje de
los estudiantes
por primera vez en méxico los profesores
de matemáticas y ciencias podrán
participar en el campeonato de canacar
en se trata de un programa de 10 semanas
en el cual con los profesores podrán
aprovechar el contenido de la plataforma
e impulsar así el aprendizaje de sus
estudiantes con un reto muy divertido al
inscribirse los profesores podrán
agregar a sus alumnos asignarles tareas
y ejercicios personalizados y revisar su
progreso como parte exclusiva del
campeonato tendremos una serie de
actividades de mentalidad de crecimiento
que hemos diseñado con un grupo de
investigación de la universidad de
stanford estas actividades fueron
pensadas para ayudar a los estudiantes a
desarrollar habilidades y estrategias
para tener mentes más fuertes y superar
retos los alumnos ganarán premios y
medallas virtuales para celebrar su
esfuerzo y su dedicación les compartimos
un ejemplo de la emoción que este
programa ha generado en brasil y en eeuu
el campeonato correrá del 10 de
septiembre al 16 de noviembre las
inscripciones se abren el 13 de agosto
el programa es 100% gratuito y online
visite www.ubm.com peonato punto o
hereje e inscríbete se parte de este
reto único para este regreso a clases
working de que albert tiene sentido
wayne de quien te robe vamos méxico
[Música]